- Okay, you know what?
Actually, I wanted to
give a special shout out
to my kids' grandparents.
Arie and Coco Kopelman, that's right.
(audience cheering)
I love them so much and it
was Arie's birthday this week
so we've been doing a lot
of celebrating of Poppy
and that's Grammy.
And I have to tell you they
told me that they've been
watching the show and they
are supremely honest with me.
Like when Arie doesn't get something
he just flat out says it.
And which is this great 'cause
I always know where I stand
with them and they're
worldly and I really trust
their opinion and tastes and honestly,
I wanna make them proud and
they're loving the show.
So hi guys, I love you.
Now, do we have any
grandparents in our VFFs today?
Joyce?
- Hi, how are you Drew?
- Hi Joyce?
- How are you?
- Arie always says
there's nothing overrated
about being a grandparent.
That's one of his famous quotes.
He's the kind of guy too
who everywhere he goes
he walks around and he
goes, isn't this the best?
It's the greatest thing.
So I call them Grammy and Poppy.
Do you have a grandparent nickname?
- I do, my grandchildren
Alice, Andrew and Branson,
they call me Mimi.
I asked to be called Gramssy
but they call Mimi so,
one happy Mimi am I.
(audience laughs)
- Well, there were definitely
pre-existing family members
who chose Grammy and Poppy so,
I was just lucky to get on the train
and I'm so glad to meet you
Joyce and thank you for sharing.
- Thank you, here say to
my little Mimi something.
- Oh,
(Joyce laughing)
well congratulations on being
an excellent grandparent.
- Thank you and
congratulations on your show.
- Thank you, Joyce.
All right, we've got a big show today
helping me close out our
second show of the week
is a wonderful, sweet, kind
and very funny friend of mine.
We were also married once,
his name is Tom Green.
And you know, it's a moment
I'm excited to share it with you.
All right and we wanna shine a light
on all the wild flowers out there.
All of the girls and
women who are breaking
down walls and making
their own paths to success.
And today we meet Sky Brown
who is a young skateboarder
and she is so brave.
And man, she's about to tell
us something that trusts me
you just don't want to miss
it, it blew my hair back.
So let's first get into some
information about the world
we live in, it's time
for some Drew's News.
(audience cheering)
(tire squeals)
(cat meows)
(dramatic music)
Sir, Ma'am, guy.
Ma'am, I asked you a question.
It's Drew's News.
All right, let's see what made the papers.
First, okay this is actually
sort of a very important
periodical to me growing up.
TV Guide has a section
called Cheers and Jeers.
And I even talked to a
journalist recently and was like,
Cheers and Jeers, it's
like, it's still out there
and it's in the latest issue of TV Guide.
And this week, guess what guys?
I'm so excited to share
this with everyone here.
Our show made the Cheers section.
(audience cheering)
Phew.
Oh my gosh, I'm not kidding.
Damian Holbrook said that we
had a divinely inspired launch.
I mean, this is such a big deal for me.
When I was a kid I
would savor my TV Guides
and I always looked to
the Cheers and Jeers
for what was like good
or couldn't be missed.
And it's a tradition
that's still going on.
I'm not kidding, I check
in regularly about it.
So cheers right back at
you Damian and TV Guide.
Thank you for the props,
that means a lot to us.
(audience cheering)
So I'm so excited for
this news I just saw.
"Father of the Bride"'s gang
is getting back together.
Today Netflix is dropping
"Father of the Bride"
We'll call it part three.
Steve Martin, Diane Keaton,
Kimberly Williams-Paisley
Martin Short, Kieran
Culkin and Nancy Meyers,
the writer, director
herself they're all back
and the reunion is benefiting
World Central Kitchen
who happens to be with friend
of the show, Jose Andres.
(audience cheering)
That's right.
Changing the world he is.
And a fun fact, I have the
DVD in our really old ancient
minivan and I play the movie
for the kids all the time.
And to this day, I get
very verklempt every time
Steve Martin is doing his
voiceovers 'cause obviously
I can't be watching while I'm
driving but I hear him talking
about the house they grew
up in and how it's like cool
in the summer and warm in the
winters and anytime you hear
a father talking about their
daughter this way I mean,
I'm just telling you oh, it's so good.
So I'm gonna be checking
that out, maybe you can too.
Okay, I don't mean to stress you out
but we're almost a month
away from Halloween.
Have you thought of a costume?
Have you thought of one
for your guinea pig?
Well, don't freak out yet
because Popsugar has posted
a guide to PetSmart's fun
and affordable costumes
for all your furball friends.
Oh, you don't have a guinea pig?
Oh, you don't care?
Well, we're gonna look at
all these photos anyway.
All right, first up for a traditionalist.
Here's a lovely pumpkin boy.
Oh, hi pumpkin boy,
there you are, oh yeah.
And then there's unicorn
princess, look at her.
And there's also a bumblebee
and a lobster and a baby dino.
Look at this cuties.
Oh, and here's one more costume
I wanted to just show you guys.
Oh, there you are, hi.
I'm telling you we're running
wild kingdom at my house.
Like my kids are always you know,
especially Olive's nickname
is literally Ace Ventura.
We're actually gonna do a
segment called Dr. Drew Little
because let's face it,
when your kids get pets,
you get pets.
All right so this one, I got the hot dog,
by the way this is Daisy, she's a boy.
(audience laughs)
And yeah, so we're gonna
turn Daisy into a winner.
(audience laughing)
Condiments hold all the fun in the world.
Daisy, thank you so much.
You're just the best.
Thank you, Daisy.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, give it up for Daisy.
(upbeat music)